mind without fear of judgment
we brought together seven strangers
Protected Their identities and created a
space for them to be completely honest
what will be revealed when they take the
mask off
I just want to say this they're not
going to be completely honest right
they're they're still sitting by other
people humans are sheep they tend to
follow what others do and you might get
a little more honesty out of this I
think is what we're going to see but I
don't believe you're going to see a
hundred percent honestly let's just say
this is this will be about as honest a
opinion that you're gonna get from uh
feminists that you're ever going to see
so let's just leave it there
foreign
someone
I don't know why they did this red agree
and blue disagree I should have been
green agree and red disagree but anyway
so look for the red dots again I have
shame and for those of you that are
maybe living under Rock somewhere don't
know what shaming is
um men are constantly accused of
slut-shaming women oh she's too
promiscuous she's been around a bunch of
guys she's like the Village bicycle but
the truth of matter is slushieming is
actually a tactic that was more or less
um you know used by women you know for
the most part
um I don't think you hear a guy say it
until their 20s or 30s or or so but
you'll hear a lot of even even teenage
girls call other uh girls uh [ __ ]
um and this even existed back when I was
in high school too
[Music]
all right
interesting
hell yeah
I mean I probably did it last week you
know what I mean like I think I don't do
it people's faces but like misogyny runs
so
here we go here we go with the
victimhood she just said but like
misogyny runs so deep right right away
let's blame
somebody else
deep I'm gonna think bad things about a
girl that's prettier than me I'm gonna
hang on did you guys hear that I'm gonna
think bad things of a girl that's
prettier than me just gonna back that up
let's just play that back again
it's prettier than me I'm gonna like oh
you know what [ __ ] I'm gonna think that
I went to Catholic school so we were
forced to sign Chastity cards like
physical cards we um had the whole
presentations where they literally would
like wrap a present and then like rip it
apart and kick it and be like this is
what happens when you have sex before
marriage and like I was definitely kind
of to some of my like a little bit of a
[Laughter]
I used to date this girl in my 20s that
worked in a bad part of Toronto and this
hand movement stuff that you're seeing
in the shadows
there was a term coin for that she
called it ghetto [ __ ]
first friends who had been like having
sex for a while or whatever it's
definitely partially a product of like
religion and the way that this whole
country is tied into protestantism and
everything as well when I was in eighth
grade there was this girl my favorite
group day was slow shame her because
it's quite the shadow because she was
always like uh hyper sexual and um once
me and her got close I found out that
she was sexually assaulted and so you
know ever since she told me her story I
stopped so shaming even if I don't agree
with what someone is doing I just say
that is their business and they will
take it up with God on their judgment
day it don't got nothing to do with me
I've used my sexuality for personal gain
it'll be interesting
[Music]
listen four agree three disagree
all right let's see what this one here
starts with if I'm going to be oppressed
of course again it's you know it's a
victim mindset what did I get what do I
say about the victim mindset the victim
mindset it's a loser's mindset you want
to avoid anybody that comes at you uh
number three on my red flag list is the
unhappy and The Unlucky just stay away
from these people but here we go
listen if I'm going to be oppressed for
it I'm gonna use it to my advantage when
I want to like it's something that is
unavoidable if I'm going to be a press
for it again the question is I've used
my sexuality for personal gain
I'm going to use it
uh I'm still trying to get my head
around how you're oppressed today you
know as a woman I mean
I've covered this in so many different
shows it's just like it just gets old oh
I'm oppressed I'm so oppressed by by
whom exactly and for what exactly
um and you have the advantage and you
just admitted it right here that you use
your sexuality for personal gain right
guys can't use their sexuality for
personal gain women pretty much all of
them can
okay
um my whole life I felt like I was
sexualized and I was an early Bloomer
too so I felt like I was constantly
sexualized as a child and when I got
like past like losing my virginity and
then being groomed and then being
assaulted and being groomed oh my God
another victim see I said this in the
book
you cannot be a feminist without being a
victim simultaneously because for them
to be oppressed for them to have
oppressors they have to be victims right
being groomed I was assaulted I was it
was like maybe she was right but like
you know when they start talking about
you know I'm using these things to my
advantage when I shouldn't be
yeah you know
you get the idea
I thought to the age where I was like
that's so [ __ ] up that it was
kind of like a like a revelation for
myself being like it's what'll get me
like what I need I'll use it yeah you
know like if I'm gonna get cat called I
might as well get something out of it
like not monetary personal gain but yeah
so the blue one is disagree so let's see
here what this one has to say internal
personal game yeah like okay so she just
admitted to using it for her Advantage
right she just said oh not for monetary
reasons but for personal reasons I have
used it okay fitting in getting positive
reinforcement that sort of thing I still
feed into the insecurity of if I'm not
getting that like what am I worth and I
feel like that's very dangerous
because women throughout history for
millions of years have always been
Beauty objects that's the way things are
right you can never get away from that
I'll be you know getting dressed for a
night out or to go out and I'm like why
am I wanting to dress a certain way what
kind of attention do I really want to
get what kind of attention do I really
want to get why am I dressed in this way
again Beauty objects you know attention
is a currency for women
let me grab the Super Chat real quick
before we carry on with not all women
should be believed as the next one uh
hey what's up rich I'm considering joke
uh joking or joining the group of
community over the last three years I've
leveled up uh in my extremely
financially career-wise Health Etc but
one thing I'm struggling with now is
women I've never struggled with women
but I am now I need Insight what Insight
do you need man
um I'm gonna drop the join like you can
call in and ask uh whatever question you
want but I'll be honest with you you
know women is a part of what we talk
about in the community but it's not
everything
I understand that guys need feedback and
they want to run stuff up the flagpole
and we're there to help and support with
that but we talk about a lot more stuff
than just you know getting the chicks
right
not all women should be believed
[Music]
all right so we've got one two okay I'm
gonna start here got six agree and one
disagree so one just not all women
should be believed interesting and then
go and then figure out if I change
the first thing that jumped into my mind
me like go with like I agree with this
is all those stupid ass white women that
call the cops irresponsibly and without
reading reason and stuff like that
that's sort of where
stupid ass white women is where we start
okay my logic went in on this not so
much regarding like essay and stuff
not so much regarding s what is SA
is that is that seeking Arrangements
not so much regarding essay and stuff
like that you guys let me know in the
chat I'm not
I don't know was it South America essay
what is that stuff like that because I
would support any woman in that even if
she's lying I'm still going to believe
her even if she's lying I'm still going
to believe her
but we got to believe all women right
I'm not saying you know
throw it all out but come on all really
uh okay yeah sexual assault thank you I
feel like there's like a line obviously
you believe all women when it comes to
you know sexual assault but then there's
like the line that like knowing that
people are bad you know there are people
who want to do harm and if they're a
believe all women when it comes to
sexual assault like without proof or
evidence at all
really
hmm
woman that sucks you know
I guess or I guess why I went with this
is to say not immediately saying no
right away and to be like okay here we
are this happened let's talk about it
you know I think for me it comes from
the like the misogynistic like there we
go misogynistic like because somebody in
the chat
keep track of all the victim statements
they have misogyny
I don't know I've heard like three or
four of them now yeah that a lot of
women just like lie because they're like
Jezebels you know like they're just kind
of we're just like tricksters for some
reason I think a lot of people
specifically men think like oh well
they're just saying it's to get fame or
fortune or whatever and I'm like can you
name one of
um
you guys correct me if I'm wrong in the
live chat or in the comments but for the
most part
for the last few years since this metoo
stuff came out
I think most of these allegations have
for the most part been cast aside and
not been proven with some Rarities
um I think even with um
Weinstein you know for example is you
know that you know that prick
um but I think for the most part most of
the allegations have been cast aside
it's just not true that there wasn't
sufficient evidence
um but you know oh look you know here we
go can you name one of the people that
built Bill Cosby assaulted so we're
we're going back on this one here Fame
on fortune or whatever and I'm like can
you name one of the people that Bill
Cosby assaulted no um my initial similar
to you is just like yes I want to hear
what this woman has to say because I've
been likely way more in my bed in my
life than by women
has been lied to More by men than by
women but feminism is probably the
biggest lie out there
canceling men is necessary for progress
[Music]
canceling Med so the red dots again are
agree so most of them agree that
canceling men is necessary a few of them
disagree let's see what they got
if you like it double edges
how many times have I said this to you
guys women always start sentences with I
feel like
can you guys see it there on the screen
it's paused
right underneath here I feel like it's a
double-edged sword
you're going to hear weak men beta males
use language sound bites like I feel
like
intelligent men that are unplugged use
language like I think because they're
using their brain they're thinking
things through they're using a rational
deductive process to think things
through in almost all scenarios
when women are going to approach
a statement like this for example you're
going to get I feel like let's see how
many more of these we actually get here
too
let's back up a little bit
I feel like it's a double-edged sword
I'm not necessarily pro-cancel culture
but I'm pro-holding people accountable
but I feel like with canceling there it
is I feel like twice you said
she's pro-holding people accountable
can we hold women accountable though I
haven't seen it yet man I feel like we
saw this a lot with the who was that
Andrew Tate
um it was really good that we were
bringing attention to it and women saw
how much of Us come back he was and I
feel like a good amount of men did too
but at the same time it became kind of
like a joke it became entertainment for
men I agree with like accountability for
sure I feel like like canceling so she
made direct reference to our friend Mr
Tate being canceled there let me just
back that up again let's play that just
one more time
but I'm Pro holding people accountable
but I feel like with canceling men I
feel like we saw this a lot with the who
was that Andrew Tate
um it was really good that we were
bringing attention to it and women saw
how much of a scumbag he was and I feel
like a good amount of men did too but at
the same time it became kind of like a
joke it became entertainment for men I
agree with like so because men were
entertained by what he was saying he
didn't want them to hear it so cancel
them is necessary for Progress it's
basically you know what we've arrived at
here
accountability for sure this is like the
unhinged thinking that's being used I
feel like like canceling someone or
canceling a singer or rap or whatever
just like not listening to their music
or not supporting them but like men as a
system that's like not possibly whole
power so like not you know engaging with
them isn't going to like progress less
any further we have to engage with them
to progress further you need to be able
to converse with the issue to have the
issue fixed like because if you like run
to cancel someone then they're going to
be defensive and not learn anything from
it like if somebody truly and truly I
think should be canceled like fully they
should just be like convicted like you
put behind bars
foreign this is where they're trying to
go okay I've said this for years now
feminism today's version toxic feminism
is a hate and Supremacy movement
she wants to put you behind bars like
there's a crime a real crime is what
she's saying here canceling men isn't
just necessary they're saying we need to
put them behind bars like it's a crime
this is the thinking use right I'm just
going to back this up I want you to hear
it again
if somebody truly and truly I think
should be canceled like fully they
should just be like convicted like put
behind bars like there is a crime a real
crime sometimes jail doesn't even work
because like Bill Cosby's out of jail
like he cut out of a technicality and
that's why you need money to get out on
[ __ ] it's exactly I don't trust the
system I I as much as at the example I'm
currently always going back to you is
the Brock Turner case because if you
know he ripped a girl and he got six
months probations or three of it and the
way I've seen cancel culture help in
that case I feel like sometimes cancel
culture I feel like I feel like can we
talk about like the very light jail
sentences that women get for the exact
same crime man commits a crime woman
commits the exact same crime her
sentence is always much lighter but
we're not going to talk about I feel
like there at all right because that's
going to involve some thinking that some
stats
can step in where the law in our
government and our judicial system fail
abortion so so it's about taking matters
into their own hands and trying to push
it further
um last sorry second last question is
abortion is murder and I still support
it let's see what they got here is
murder and I still support it
[Music]
I think we're a good question there we
go I feel like she started
I don't want to get flamed for this no
but I think I have like I have
so you know they're changing their votes
yeah yeah
okay so the final is four disagree that
abortion is murder murder and still
support it and three agree that it is
murder but still supports it so either
way all of them support it but some of
them are saying that it is potentially
murder so I 100 anybody that wants an
abortion should have full access no
barriers everything I think and I don't
I'm not even sure I agree with saying
that it's murder but I think that
sometimes people talk about abortion
very callously and ignore the like
trauma that is associated with it even
if you have zero regrets like you are
it's the best decision you've ever made
in your life women that I've you know
listened to and heard from and read you
know opinions from it's still like a
traumatic experience I
I think you guys understand what I'm
trying to say but I think just the
weight of it
I wonder how many of these women have
had an abortion
um
you know they do have birth control
right they have very effective birth
control I like it's just Bonkers that
this is still a conversation piece in
today's day and age like I understand
there's extenuating circumstances like
rape and stuff like that but I mean if
you're dating somebody and you're not
planning on having a kid but you're
gonna be intimate be on birth control
right I mean or or just don't bang
like I don't understand why this is
still a freaking topic
experience
I think just the weight of it now has
been lessened a little bit I think that
is Shifting back again though because of
awful recent events um but I would say
for the past like five years or so I've
just heard it in my own communities like
tossed around lightly and I don't
necessarily think that it should be
handled really lightly I agree with the
latter half of this of the statement I
feel like it's like I feel like cheered
again you can hear a lot of this one
once you once you hear this
ladies and gentlemen you're going to
hear it all the time whenever you're
talking to a woman you're going to hear
it all the time I feel like I feel like
I feel like you're gonna hate me for it
sorry but there it is
if it were to be considered murder I
would still support it oh yes okay yeah
but yeah I would say
so she just
hang it she just said there that even if
it were to be deemed as murder she would
still support it
that's
that's the thinking that's being used
here this is what we're applying
bizarre because it's not it's still even
if it is murder it's not an easy Choice
like that makes it even more of a
difficult conversation you know it's
like such a deeper thing
um this question is actually making me
really emotional because
um I just gave birth in February and um
I love my son he's like
my world
but uh
pick you up
um I recently thought I was pregnant
again
oh what the hell you just gave birth in
February and you're pregnant again all
right when was this recorded October
21st
I'm not in a position to have another
baby right now
but I knew if I was making this one I
wanted to ask me anymore
so
if I just know like my some people
oh I know they wouldn't have understood
it so yeah
and that's the reality you know it's not
like people
I don't know what to say like
she just gave birth in February and she
thought that she was pregnant again like
use freaking condoms okay go on birth
control and use condoms
or maliciously trying to
you know what I mean it's like it's it's
a choice and am I going to be able to
provide for myself and my already born
child or you know is this going to be
healthy for my mental health it's not
like you are no it's not healthy for
your mental health to go through that
process absolutely not maliciously
trying to destroy a couple of cells if I
like how they reduce it to a clump of
cells it's just a clump of cells
it's your life and that matters more
than in my opinion than any kind of
potential yeah absolutely I feel like
because of this I feel like because of
this of this the dissolve of Roe v Wade
like I feel like I don't even want to
try to have kids anymore like they're
they're doing the opposite thing to us
there's only one who want to try but who
there's we've heard the stories a little
miscarriages and go in and try to get
seen by doctors and say we can't do this
we call your lawyer and I have so many
health issues I have endometriosis I
have everything under the female Sun
maybe take care of yourself better
exercise lose weight eat healthier food
start there you could exist I could very
easily carry a I can see that's not good
yeah I could very easily die from my
topic pregnancy and the fear that if for
one day this expanded and reached where
I live I could die you know and it's so
scary and it deters women like me who
are on the fence
so she's trying to say that
if I get pregnant I could die
and if I don't have access to abortion
then that's not good for me
this logic
logic it's not even wanting to have kids
it's not even logic it's just feeling
the future isn't female
[Music]
as much as I want to fight for all right
statement the future isn't female we've
got five that agree and two that
disagree let's see what they got or if I
see this misogyny in my brothers and you
know my father even told me when I was
in high school I asked them I said do
you think women are men are superior to
women and he said yeah to my face I'm
his oldest daughter
his only daughter you know so that hurts
and to see that it puts a really gray
tone over the world for you I guess I'm
super radical and I'm like just end all
of this stuff like that and so I feel
like feminism is like is for the time
being I want to end gender as a whole I
think it's binding
what the hell did she just say I want to
end gender as a whole
it's like it's for the time being I want
to end gender as a whole I want to end
gender as a whole because I think it's
binding
it's like saying I want to end the Sun
or I want to end the oceans and the sea
how do you how do you end something
that's
I'm sorry I'm putting you through this
but this is just to prove a point okay
this is
this is just being a fly in the wall
listen to them
be as honest as they want to be on these
on these statements which I think it's
binding and it's it's oppressive so I
feel like the future is neither female
nor male I don't know I do like the
concept of Ginger because it to some
degree it is not who we are as a whole
but it does make us I'm like identifying
as a woman and also if you're born as a
woman and you can get pregnant and give
birth you're a woman
and identify as a stapler if you want
but you're still female I I'll challenge
that by saying who are going to be the
ones to be the voices for queer people
and non-binaries because it's not going
to be success
uh you're gonna have to you're gonna
have to forgive me as a older gentleman
a seasoned gentleman but when I read
this stuff
I mean the sentence reads for queer
people and non-binaries because it's not
going to be CIS hetero men
I don't even know what sis hetero man
means
that's true yeah
foreign
much
Jesus hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out